[موسيقى]
نعم سياسه اوروبا خاطئه والاوكران والغرب
هم من يدفعون الثمن هكذا فجرتها هنغاريا
وجيوش الجو تحلق فوق سماء روسيا واوكرانيا
والمعارك تلتهم وبعد ان ارسل قائدها الى
الجحيم ها هو بوتين يحتضن فاجنار
تعلنها انتهت المرحله الصعبه وما بقي الا
القليل فعن اي مرحله يتحدثون وتعزيز بحري
جديد في القوات الاوكرانيه فما هو الهدف
واكبر اقتصاد اوروبي في ورطه والعين ترمق
الجانب الروسي النيجر تعلن حاله التاهب
القصوى وليبيا تدخل خطا ازمه النيجر
والجيوش تتحرك بينما اعطت نيام مهله يومين
فقط لفرنسا
فما الذي يجري وجيوش الصين تغزو سماء
تايوان فهل اقتربت الحرب اكثر
اوروبا تعترف عندما يجر الخطا اخاه تصبح
العوده اشبه بالمستحيله واخطاء اوروبا لا
تنتهي تجاه الدب الروسي والاوروبيون
يعلمون ذلك جيدا وها هو شاهد منهم يعلن
ذلك حيث قال رئيس وزرائهم جاريا فيكتور
اوربان ان استراتيجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق بالنزاع في
اوكرانيا خاطئه والاوكرانيون والاوروبيون
يدفعون ثمنها لتصبح المانيا اول واكبر من
يدفع الثمن حيث كشف التقارير اعلاميه
لوكاله فرانسبريس ان ازمه الطاقه انهكت
اكبر اقتصاد اوروبي وهي المانيا فيما دعى
وزير الاقتصاد الالماني روبرت هافيك الى
التحرك لتحسين الاداء الاقتصادي هذا
التسجيل نسبه نمو صفريه لان الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي الوطني في الربع الثاني فيا لها
من نكسه اقتصاديه قد تقود القاره باكملها
الى الحضيض
الى الحرب التي جعلت اوروبا تعيش وضعا
كهذا نعم انها الحرب الاوكرانيه ففي جو
المعارك اعلنت السلطات الروسيه احباط هجوم
اوكراني بمسيارتين على موسكو على الحدود
بين البلدين وهو ما ادى الى تعليق الرحلات
في ثلاث مطارات في العاصمه الروسيه ليتم
استئناف الحركه لاحقا فيما قال حاكم
مقاطعه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت قريه ارزوفو
بذخائر عنقوديه من راجمه صواريخ بان طراز
جراد سقطت على بيوت سكنيه خاصه وعلى مخزن
ريفي اما في الجو الاوكراني فذكرت شبكه سي
ان ان نقلا عن ضابط في القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الجويه الروسيه تعمل
24 ساعه في اليوم ولذلك فهي تمنعهم من
التقدم لكن المعارك ملتهبه يا ساده ولا
شيء يوقف رائحه البارود وهنا افادت قياده
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه بانها دمرت
مسيرتين من نوع شاهد في مقاطعه خارقياف
شمال شرقي البلاد لتعود وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وتعلن عن صدق قواتها عشرات
الهجمات الروسيه في خمسه محاور رئيسيه على
الجبهتين الشرقيه والجنوبيه وقالت ان
القوات الروسيه شنت 62 غاره جويه ونفذت 89
هجوما صاروخيا ومدفعيا الرد الروسي لا
يتاخر حيث كانت موسكو قد اعلنت اسقاط 73
طائره مسيره اوكرانيه استهدفت جزيره القرم
في حين قالت كييف ان على سكان موسكو ان
يشعروا بويلات الحرب التي تشنها بلادهم
وباعداد الكهنه لابد من مصدر وها هو
المصدر يتحدث امامكم
حديث عن هجمات قد شنتها القوات الروسيه
خلال الساعات 24
المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قد اعلن امس ان هناك كانت يعني
الاستهداف في المسيرات الاوكرانيه بينما
كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت ان
قواتها تصدت بنجاح للهجمات الاوكرانيه على
محاور القتال الرئيسيه خلال 24 ساعه وقضت
علامه مجموعه نحو 690 جنديا للعدو
الاخيره يفرض ضغطا شديدا على القوات
الروسيه في باخما ورجح التقرير البريطاني
ان تدفع المكاسب الميدانيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه روسيا للعوده للاسلوب الهجومي
هل علينا حقا ان ننتظره هجوما روسيا من
جديد اذا فما هي الهجمات والضربات حاصله
حاليا هل كانت مجرد مقبلات وعلى ذات
الصعيد اعلنت البحريه الاوكرانيه ان وحده
منفصله للمسيره البحريه دخلت الخدمه كجزء
من قواتها ويبدو ان الهدف هو اسطول موسكو
في البحر الاسود وهنا ننتقل الى
مجددا حيث قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه يتم البحث عن كيفيه سقوط طائره قائد
مجموعه فاجنر
واشار الى انه لا يمكنه التحدث بحريه عن
هذا الامر وليس لديهما يقوله بشانه بينما
كان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وبعد
ساعات من تقديمه العزاء في قائد مجموعه قد
وقع مرسوما يلزم عناصر جميع المجموعات
المسلحه غير النظاميه مثل مجموعه فاجنر
باداء القسم مثل ما يفعل جنود الجيش
وبموجب نص المرسوم فقد بات لزاما على
افراد المجموعات المسلحه غير النظاميه
التعهد بالاخلاص والوفاء لروسيا والامتثال
الصارم لاوامر القاده والمسؤولين الاعلى
رتبه وكان بوتين يقولها لام ميليشيا بعد
اليوم وبين هذا وذاك كان الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي مرسيلنس كقاديل التقى وزير الخارجيه
التركي هاكان فيدال الذي زار كياف بحث
الطرفان عده ملفات من بينها ازمه تصدير
الحبوب وسبل تحقيق السلام مع روسيا بينما
سيلتقي اردوغان مع بوتين خلال الفتره
القادمه للوساطه ايضا في ازمه الحرب وازمه
الغذاء فهل يفعلها اردوغان هذه المره
الاحداث والتطورات بينما كان مجلس
الانقلاب في النيجر قد امهل السفير
الفرنسي 48 ساعه للرحيل من اراضيها ظهرت
اخبار اخرى بان المجلس اعطى ذات المهله
كذلك لكل من سفراء الولايات المتحده
والمانيا ونيجيريا لمغادره البلاد كذلك
لكن وزاره خارجيه النيجر نفت انها طلبت
ذلك من سفراء الولايات المتحده والمانيا
ونيجيريا لتبقى المهله فقط مخصصه للسفاره
الفرنسيه من جهتها رفضت فرنسا قرار المجلس
العسكري في النيجر طرد سفيرها في نيامي
معتبره ان هذا القرار لا يمكن اتخاذه الا
من قبل السلطات النيجيريه المنتخبه لتضع
اركان جيش النيجر في رساله داخليه الى وضع
افراد الجيش في حاله تاهب القصوى واوضح
رئيس الاركان النيجيري ان هذا القرار اتخذ
على خلفيه التهديدات المتزايده بالعدوان
على النيجر ويهدف الاستبعاد المفاجاه
العامه وضمان الرد المناسب لتدخل ليبيا
على الخط حيث اعلنت الحكومه الليبيه
المكلفه من البرلمان حاله الطوارئ القصوى
على الحدود مع النيجر وذلك لتامين حدود
بلادها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
انها رصدت خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه دخول عشرين طائره تابعه للقوات
الجويه الصينيه الى منطقه الدفاع الجوي
للجزيره وعبرت الطائره ومنها مقاتلات
وطائره مسيره خط الوسط لمضيق تايوان والذي
كان في السابق حاجزا غير رسمي بين
الجانبين
[موسيقى]